during certain periods of my life i have
a very difficult time
focusing on pretty much anything
important or difficult
during these periods it seems almost
impossible to break
out of the social media limbo where
you're just constantly switching between
tabs
refreshing pages kind of waiting for
something interesting to happen
like for someone to post a cool photo on
instagram or something you're kind of
waiting to be entertained but if you
actually have to apply yourself
it's extremely difficult borderline
painful to do so
and i'm pretty sure almost everyone can
relate to this problem
i'm sure you've seen a lot of videos on
youtube giving you little tips and
tricks as to how to focus better
including my own channel but there are
very few videos
kind of diving in talking about why it's
so difficult to focus
on hard things you know like what's the
deal why can't we just sit down and do
something important with very little
strain
why aren't we motivated to do the things
that would significantly
advance us further in our lives because
it's not like we don't want those things
it's just hard so in this video i want
to dive into
why we procrastinate why it's so hard to
do important things
because knowing how this all works helps
us carve out a long-term
solution it can help us permanently
solve this problem and that may sound
really ambitious
but i do believe it is possible but
first we kind of have to
discover a little bit more about our
human brain so weird thing about our
human brain
our human brain i'm really trying to
convince you that i'm human the weird
thing about the brain
is that it pretty much hasn't changed
for thousands of years
we share for the most part the exact
same brain as our hunter-gatherer
ancestors
and this is the type of brain that was
evolved to scan
vast valleys for the prospect of food or
a fresh kill
and absolutely light up and get excited
at the sight of an antelope
so you can gather your friends together
and run after it kill it this is the
kind of brain
that as you're kind of going through a
berry bush and you find a juicy berry
you're super excited you eat the berry
and it pretty much makes your day you
know it's not really exciting stuff
there wasn't a lot of stuff to do back
then
but that's just kind of the way it was
and the reason why we were motivated to
go run after an antelope
or eat a fresh berry is the same reason
wow is the same reason we're motivated
to go on facebook and you know check our
notifications
go on instagram etc the reason why we're
motivated to do any of this stuff is
because of a brain chemical called
dopamine
now you've probably seen a lot of videos
on youtube if you're into
self-improvement
about dopamine but dopamine is kind of
misunderstood
because most people think it's the
feel-good chemical
it's a brain chemical that's released
when you're experiencing pleasure it's
the reason why you experience pleasure
but that's not exactly true
because dopamine is the motivating brain
chemical
dopamine is what's released when you
feel like you're about to be rewarded or
when you feel like you're about to
experience something pleasurable
when your ancient ancestors saw the
antelope frolic across the field
they got a squirt of dopamine which
motivated them to go kill it when you
see a notification
pop up on facebook you get a squirt of
dopamine which motivates you to click it
and what this means is that dopamine
is what controls your motivation thank
you boys
oh did you get a big mcchicken yeah you
said make chicken now why is this
important despite the fact that we
share the exact same brains as our
hunter-gatherer ancestors
we don't live in that world anymore we
live in a world of supernormal stimuli
through ferocious technological
advancement and
capitalistic ventures or whatever you
want to call it we live in a world where
things are designed to be as pleasurable
as humanly possible
and what supernormal stimuli does is it
hijacks our natural
reward pathways it tricks our brain into
thinking
we are about to do something so
important for our survival
that we have an almost irresistible urge
towards doing that thing a good example
of this
is junk food food is integral for our
survival
and high calorie foods are usually even
more important for our survival
because you know they'll keep us alive
longer the more calories
the longer we'll live roughly speaking
see what junk food does
is it's mechanically engineered to be as
high fat high calorie as possible so
when we get that
beautiful we when we eat that beautiful
potato chip our brain remembers that
and the next time we see a bag of potato
chips at the grocery store
there's a huge amount of dopamine that's
released
motivating you to go grab that reward
that reward that's integral for your
survival so we almost become
slaves to our dopamine system we almost
just go where our dopamine system
tells us to go that's why we get into
kind of social media binge
because our brain is telling us to stay
on
these social media sites because there's
a chance that we might get a reward
we might get social validation where we
we might be able to
look at something kind of stimulating
and naughty it's the dopamine system
that's telling us and motivating us to
stay there so what does this all mean if
we're bringing this all together
basically for most of us who have
difficulty focusing
we find it really really difficult to be
motivated to do harder things
that is only because we have
reprogrammed our brain
to fall for this super normal stimuli
rather than
normal stimuli natural stimuli because
it's not that these
natural rewards aren't rewarding they're
just less rewarding than the
artificial supernormal rewards so the
long-term solution to be able to focus
on boring things
is to reprogram our brain to remember
that these things are actually
pleasurable
and really good for us and integral for
our survival and this isn't just about
a dopamine fast for a couple of days or
something like that
we almost need to reset our baseline
long term we need to think about how
much stimulation we want
in our lives what kind of super normal
stimulus do we want to take
part in you know i've noticed in my own
life that when i'm camping for a long
period of time
and there isn't much to do other than
figure out how to cook a fish over a
fire or set up my tent
or go for a walk in the woods or go
swimming or lay on the sand
in these situations little things like
having a conversation with a sibling or
a friend
becomes immensely pleasurable it's the
same reason why people who break out of
an addiction cycle
they stop doing their immensely
pleasurable thing
cold turkey after a certain amount of
time they find an
increased enjoyment out of life itself
pretty much everything in life becomes
more enjoyable
they start to find motivation to do
things other than their addiction
you know it's something that i also
noticed during the quarantine why it was
so hard for me to
find my work ethic again it's because
all that time inside
made me an internet addict i spent so
much time looking at
screens that my baseline of dopamine and
stimulation was so high
that the more boring things became
almost painful to do in comparison
the disparity of stimulation became so
vast
that i felt physical pain trying to do
harder things so if we're able to find a
way to
genuinely enjoy the things that make our
lives better
then what are we doing like why don't we
just go and do that i really want to
challenge you guys
over the next couple of weeks or months
to really think about how much
stimulation you want to invite into your
life
you know what's actually adding value to
your life and can you reduce the amount
of
super supernormal stimuli that you're
indulging in on a daily basis
you may actually find that by reducing
your amount of time on social media or
on youtube
or eating junk food or you name it you
may actually come to
genuinely look forward to socializing
you might actually look forward to
reading a book you might actually be
motivated to go to the gym there will be
that dopamine driver
pointing you in that direction creating
an irresistible
urge to go to the gym like who would
have thought that's possible
and it is possible because it's science
one way that i'm going to make sure i
stick to this over the next month
at least is i made a list of a large
amount of things that are fairly low
stimulus that i can do instead of doing
a more stimulating alternative that
includes things like
going for a walk reading a book talking
with a friend
skyping a friend going to the gym by
having that list in your hand
you'll have a automatic response to that
urge to go do the the thing like you
know
eat a bag of chips or something so i'll
make a follow-up video on my second
channel
on how that all went i really encourage
you guys to do the same thing
and if you're looking for more
activities that don't over stimulate you
then i'd highly recommend checking out
videos on skillshare
and use it as an alternative to watching
videos on youtube
because youtube is like candy if you eat
too much of it you're just gonna feel
not so good whereas skillshare is like a
hearty steak dinner
it tastes good and it's good for you for
those of you who don't know
skillshare is an online learning
community with thousands of classes
covering dozens of topics everything
from photography to cooking to coding
skillshare empowers you to accomplish
real growth
and that's because their classes are
extremely practical
i'm taking yet another cinematography
class on skillshare
and i find it really easy to just take
what i'm learning on skillshare
and apply it directly to my real-life
pursuits and one of the other great
things about skillshare is that it's
extremely affordable
especially when you compare it to online
classes or workshops
if you pay for the annual membership it
comes in at less than ten dollars a
month
so it's kind of a no-brainer and
skillshare is doing this awesome thing
where the first
1000 of you who click the link in the
description below
we'll get two months of skillshare
premium absolutely free
so make sure you click below and take
advantage of that
learn something new explore your
creativity
and have a great time if you like this
video make sure to hit like
because when you hit like the algorithm
blesses me
by shoving this video in front of other
people's faces
helping them out which also helps me out
so it's kind of a win-win for everybody
if you're lurking here and this is the
billionth time
you've seen my bald head
what are you doing hit subscribe already
and make sure you hit the bell icon so
that you don't miss future videos
and if you haven't discovered my second
channel yet i will link that in the
description
i'm posting kind of a weekly and
bi-weekly
q a videos they're super me super fun
and i'll occasionally post vlogs there
as well so make sure you check that out
but that's kind of it for today thank
you so much for watching and we'll catch
you in the next video
[Music]
you